You guys remember my daughter's cup that got stolen?
It was never found. This is like literally the next school year,
but I got her a new cup from Yogi.
I loved it so much. It was
the exact design that I loved
was that you can open this part for open mouth drinking,
so she can, like,
you know, practice that skill.
But then it also has the straw
for moments when she wants to drink from the straw.
But here's why I like the milky cup so much better.
And I'm kind of glad the damn cup got stolen,
because most cups have this hard handle, but milky
makes it easy to switch it out with a soft handle.
And they just click into place.
So they also come in, like a bajillion cute little colors and, like,
swirly colors and different sizes.
Already putting stickers on them.
I love my new Miyoko Cup. Link right here in the TikTok shop.
And they're just a cute little company cause they stepped up,
so. Yeah,
that's what happened. The cup is gone,
but we have a better one anyway.